cela vous qui a dit ça enfin une paye
moi j'appelle ça une aumône
[Rires]
très très connu et vous êtes et vous
allez me dire si ça vous choque ou pas
un comédien c'est un comédien
âgé
quand je vais vous dire le nom du
comédien ce qui fait est le salaire vous
me direz si vous êtes choqué ou pas ou
si on a on arrête un peu la démagogie
Gérard Hernandez
et cette fois-ci il a pas dit je suis
Jordan Deluxe bizarrement c'est passé
d'être malade Jordan ce jour-là je sais
pas il fait 16 interview par jour qui
commence toujours par tu gagnes combien
tu couches avec qui
est très fort
mais là c'était dans les grosses têtes
regardez
[Musique]
c'est fini vous jouez
plus rien avec ce que taverno vous paye
pour jouer Raymond tous les soirs
justement
je vous prie d'être poli avec mon ami
Nicolas
et pardon si vous venez de nous
rejoindre je pense à ça les lunettes en
deux secondes j'arrête de faire le
quadra qui s'accroche au tapis je me
dirige vers un quinca sexy donc petit
look je fais des cheveux plus longs sur
les côtés un petit peu lunettes et je
trouve que la phrase de par Dieu que
j'adorais qui était le meilleur moyen de
ne pas faire vieux c'est de ne pas
chercher à faire jeune donc c'est bien
parfait
encore un peu de jaune
alors la tête j'appelle ça une aumône
est-ce que quelqu'un connaît son salaire
non moi je m'en souviens plus il me
l'avait dit mais je m'en fous
je crois ah oui oui oui
c'est 8000 € non mais attends j'avais un
trou mais oui je l'ai raté
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est un zapping hier on
prépare l'émission et je lui dis on
m'appelle Gérard Hernandez et je lui dis
ça serait bien que tu donnes l'info toi
et pas moi il touche 8000 euros par mois
pour faire ça et tu le diras ouais ouais
et là ça donne Jean-Mi
quand même tu sais un petit peu non ah
oui oui
il m'a envoyé un texto merci mon chat et
cela dit en boutade
plusieurs séquences il tourne pas il
tourne sur 4 jours tout est séquences
alors c'est vrai que certains disent
qu'on revanche ils sont payés la même
chose que d'autres petits nouveaux
d'autres connais pas les noms du tout
alors qu'il a quand même une carrière
qu'est-ce qu'on pense de ça est-ce que
c'est maladroit dire une au monde voilà
8000 c'est vraiment une blague
pour l'instant voilà donc Janine qui
veut dire un mot
merci non mais c'est pas énorme 8000
euros pour une série comme ça sur M6 ça
me paraît on connaît les salaires on va
passer non plus donc on sait très bien
combien sont payés les comédiens sur ce
genre de série les séries TF1 sur doute
plus mais ça m'étonne 3 jours
on se calme c'est c'est
8000 par mois à peu près et il tourne on
va dire en 4 jours toutes leurs
séquences du mois Benoît et sans vouloir
rester chance avec les Benoît quand il
va sur les mystères de l'amour il a 50
phrases il fait il se change il fait une
phrase pour l'épisode 1 une phrase pour
l'épisode donc quand il prend sa pige à
400 balles en fait vous le voyez dans 5
épisodes et il a fait une pige donc
c'est pas la même chose mais le rythme
honnêtement super tendu il a quand même
90 ans pardon mais c'est super dur
d'être en disant et les sketchs sont
très difficiles à dire contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire c'est vachement
dur de retenir les trucs on dit juste la
question c'était est-ce que dire
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que c'est moi
moi j'aime bien qu'ils le dise ça me
dérange pas mais là ça choque moi je
trouve pas ça drôle en fait il a 90 ans
qu'il arrête mais non mais c'est pas des
magots c'est pas drôle
ou pas
de prendre systématiquement les
téléspectateurs pour des gens savent
très bien ce que gagne un avocat un
acteur un machin c'est limite ce sont
des métiers dangereux au cinéma à la
télévision on gagne beaucoup d'argent ça
peut s'arrêter rayon tous on est obligé
il y en a qui ont pas grand chose mais
c'est vrai vu toutes les placements de
produits
non mais c'est vrai malheureusement
c'est ça aussi c'est que malheureusement
les gens à la maison quand ils vous
voient à la télé ils sont persuadés
qu'on est tous logés à la même enseigne
il y en a qui gagne pas grand chose il y
en a qui aiment pas beaucoup et je suis
désolé 8000 euros je trouve que c'est
quand même plutôt confortable par mois
et c'est vrai que je peux comprendre que
des personnes soient choquées quand à la
fin du mois avec 1500 balles ben que le
18 du mois tu as l'impression que vous
mettez tout au même niveau
[Applaudissements]
attends une escale le mec il dit comme
ça dans une émission c'est fait pour
faire rire il est dans une dans un
concept ou une boivent rire et nous on
fait ça on fait ça finalement il est
quelle heure avec ça mais moi peut-être
que je vais me faire insulter mais quand
j'entends un animateur à la télévision
parfois de jeux tu sais où de la fortune
machin dire Nadine Nadine vous allez
gagner 800 €, c'est une somme énorme le
mec il l'a pris en une minute 10 dans la
loge moi je joue pas ce que tu es pas
soit juste sincère voilà 800 euros c'est
beaucoup pour elle pour lui c'est que
dalle juste soyez honnête et il y a il y
a autre chose surtout c'est que je sais
pas si vous avez remarqué mais le 17 il
y avait un prime spécial de scène de
ménage dans lequel Marion Games
appartenait n'était pas là et en fait il
y a le le
l'acteur Georges Beller qui a dit que
je l'embrasse qui a dit que Marion Game
malheureusement avait des petits
problèmes de mémoire et absolument en
fait partir de là elle est très fatiguée
elle va peut-être ne plus faire les miss
du coup parce qu'il perd sa partenaire
des cousines
Monville tout ça scène de ménage je te
laisse
les infos sont au top les infos sont au
top je te promets non non mais c'est pas
discuter